après les combats la détresse des
dizaines de milliers d'éthiopiens du
tigre et sont contraints de quitter leur
région largement touchée par des
affrontements sanglants ces dernières
semaines ils se réfugient dans des camps
au sein de pays voisins comme le soudan
dans celui d'achat bas où vivent 16000
personnes des médecins offrent
gratuitement des soins aux déplacés nous
avons suffisamment de soignants mais
nous rencontrons certains problèmes il
n'avons pas d'abri nous n'avons pas de
lit pas de chambre ou dormons par terre
nous sommes des professionnels de la
santé
c'est donc difficile et nous n'avons pas
de salaire nous offrons un service
gratuit
donc c'est difficile de vivre ici c'est
un défi je suis un professionnel de la
santé c'est difficile d'expliquer ce qui
s'est passé et l'arménie beaucoup de
gens viennent dans notre centre de santé
avec des blessures par balles et nous
avons du mal à soigner les patients qui
sont arrivées de plusieurs endroits à
cause des événements le tigre est
désormais dans une situation humanitaire
dramatique compte quasi exclusivement
sur les actions de l'onu ce mercredi le
gouvernement éthiopien accorder un accès
aux nations unies sans aucune limitation
l'inquiétude grandit d'heure en heure
les camps doivent maintenant être à
court de biens alimentaires ce qui rend
plus réel la menace de faim et de
malnutrition depuis le 4 novembre la
région dissidente est privé de tout
approvisionnement
une date qui coïncide avec l'envoi de
l'armée fédérale par le premier ministre
éthiopien en vue de démanteler le front
de libération du peuple du tigré avant
le conflit ce plus de 600000 tigré
independent est exclusivement de l'aide
alimentaire
la zone est désormais quasiment coupée
du monde